please welcome the hilarious baby
robinson
wow
[Applause]
i i brought it for you i got the wig on
i'm giving you garden party
okay and you always know that a good wig
comes in handy in fact do you like
always have one on i always have i have
it in my purse i just keep a wig you
never know you know never know what's
going on i shaved above the knee for you
oh my god
by the way
phoebe i recently shaved two yes oh my
gosh yes it's a big deal it is a big
deal life is busy yeah um first up i sat
on my bed last night and your title is
haunting me why did you come up with
this title you know i think
anyone who's black and has black parents
like your your parents are like we gotta
keep this house clean so phil and
octavia were like no joke we would come
home from school and they were like
strip down go shower and then you can
relax and then i didn't think it stuck
with me and then in college like i was
so militant i would be like you can't
sit on my bed and you're in a dorm room
there's like no there's no couch inside
like you can sit on the corner but like
half a butt cheek has to hang off like i
was
that makes sense like dorm room studio
apartments by the way oh my gosh she has
not seen the cover of her book yet
and a hardcover you ready
[Applause]
wow all right so no outside clothes on
the bed yes any other non-negotiables i
at this point i am 36 years old i do not
share fries anymore i am done
because people are like oh i'll just
have one i'm not another like
and i'm like
i didn't get any fries so i do not share
a little snacky things get your own
fries
well something you can do with other
people is play games and i am a major
game player and i gotta tell you we're
gonna play a game called mash does
anyone know what mash is does anyone
remember math
okay so before the show phoebe and i
both gave our list yes um all right um
can you explain the game mash really
quickly to anybody who's watching um or
here who might not know what it is yeah
so you remember like before phones when
we just had pieces of paper and
friendship
so you would just like sit with your
friends and like it stands for
was it mansion apartment shack house
house yeah and you just pick different
categories like who your house is gonna
be how many kids you're gonna have like
where you're gonna live yeah all those
kind of things and then you would just
play it and like be like oh i want like
three kids with like you know usher um
okay well before the show we each played
for each other and now it's time to show
the results i'm gonna read yours first
okay okay
you are married to hannibal lecter
okay um you have 18 000 kids
um you are a tennis player okay yes i
love tennis this is my favorite sport
well okay this was your list
um
and uh you live in london i love that
okay i love because my boyfriend's
british so i love london you know what
hannibal lecter in london is doable well
and you drive a g wagon oh energy wagon
okay yes i should have been like
tennis champion not just like a player
right like i know it's your fantasy okay
what is my fantasy slash reality what do
i get in mash i can't wait to hear about
my life phoebe okay your spout oh this
is a good one your spouse is trevor noah
i mean you don't understand i have the
biggest crush on him i always have he is
he's the complete package yes like i
have the hots for ted koppel growing up
um and david letterman who both kind of
actually have like a similar sexy
alfredy newman
newscaster vibe so this is great okay
wait i think so i'm excited about my
husband okay perfect here you have 1 000
kids
better than your 18 000.
okay um
she is tired uh i mean and
understandably so
mine's just taking a nap yeah
okay your job is you are ad man and
woman that's great i have always wanted
to be in advertising it's storytelling
you have finite time to capture the
attention get your point across and like
get someone to emote oh that's great you
you would i want to say by the way
earlier like
i want you to be my therapist because
you shut it down you like gave all the
knowledge you were vulnerable you did
not come from a place of judgment it was
incredible i was like backstage i was
like and do what else
okay what else should i do i mean i'm
just saying
it was really good it was so good um
okay you're gonna live in idaho i love
idaho bring it on okay great
and then your car is an el camino oh
yeah it is
and i'm driving and trevor's in the
passenger seat we're
in idaho yes
which is awesome
and we have 1 000 children yes it's a
lot i mean this is see this is just so
fun i mean thank you phoebe really for
kind of showing how it's done you're
very prolific you have two dope queens
on hbo you are a publisher
you make us laugh
i gotta laugh i gotta have a sense of
humor i gotta stay light i will not stay
stuck i will not stay in the dark but it
is people like you who put the funny out
there so thank you thank you so much and
congratulations on your brand new book
you hold it up that's right phoebe's
book please don't sit on my bed and your
outside clothes is available right now
[Music]
you